est ouverte
le compte rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribué
nous n'avons pas reçu d'observation
il y en a qui en séance
je n'en vois pas
le compte rendu analytique donc est
adopté
sous les réserves d'usage
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues j'aurais simplement rappelé
que le Sénat hier rendu un hommage à nos
policiers
tués dans un terrible accident hier et
manifesté sa solidarité et aussi ses
pensées à l'infirmière du CHU de Reims
assassiné je dois dire que ça doit être
l'occasion de nous rassembler autour
d'un certain nombre de valeurs je
voulais le rappeler
notre ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
notre séance est retransmise en direct
sur Public Sénat et sur notre site
d'internet chacun sera attentif au cours
de nos échanges au respect des valeurs
essentielles de notre assemblée le
respect le respect des uns et des autres
et le respect du temps la parole est au
président Jean-Claude Roquier pour le
groupe du Rassemblement démocratique
social
européen monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le président madame la Première
ministre je souhaite vous interroger sur
votre responsabilité en matière de
planification écologique et énergétique
l'urgence climatique n'est plus à
démontrer nous déplorons sur le
territoire en particulier à l'Occitanie
ou à sécheresse c'est ça le désormais
sans répit
je souligne aussi que le langagement
européen nous impose d'accélérer la
réduction des gaz à effet de serre d'ici
2030 en France ils ont seulement baissé
de 25% depuis 1990 loin des 55% attendu
vous avez annoncé le dernier un plan
d'action avec des objectifs chiffrés mon
groupe est très attentif à cible nous
souhaitons avant tout que les forces
soient équitables juste comme vous
l'avez d'ailleurs rappelé en effet
entreprise mais là je vais pouvoir
public doit participer au défi de
l'adaptation climatique mais chacun
selon ses moyens il faudra être
extrêmement ambitieux sur tous les fonds
celui de la conversion des outils de
production agricole industrielle ou
encore celui de la lutte contre le
gaspillage de l'eau y compris des eaux
grises et usées dans les normes d'usage
devront être rapidement révisées pour
compenser le déficit croissant à nos
clairs tout cela va nécessiter un
accompagnement conséquent je pense en
particulier au collectivités locales qui
devront être soutenus pour faire face à
leurs besoins nombreux en matière de
révolution énergétique des
caractéristiques des questions des
déchets ou de mobilité celle-ci
bénéficie déjà du fond vert puisqu'il
est question de planifier l'écologie le
fond vert sera-t-il pérennisé à long
terme avec quel montant au-delà des 2
milliards d'euros déjà prévus et quel
bilan d'étapes pouvez-vous en faire
pour vous répondre à la parole est à
madame la Première ministre j'avais la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le Président Jean-Claude
Roquier je veux tout d'abord à mon tour
exprimer toute ma solidarité au collègue
et aux proches des agents décédés
tragiquement ces derniers jours et
exprimez tous mon soutien tout le
soutien de mon gouvernement aux agents
qui s'engagent chaque jour pour nous
protéger nous soigner assurer
l'éducation de nos enfants et parfois
malheureusement au péril de leur vie
européen nous sommes en avance sur nos
objectifs
2019-2023 et nous avons pratiquement
rattrapé le retard accumulé sur la
période 2015-2018 mais il nous faut
encore accélérer et doubler le rythme de
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre depuis le mois de septembre
avec les ministres et l'ensemble des
acteurs nous avons identifié secteur par
secteur les leviers à actionner pour
baisser nos émissions et pour être
acceptable vous l'avez souligné l'effort
doit être juste et équitablement réparti
la moitié reviendra aux entreprises
notamment les grandes entreprises un
quart sera réalisé par l'État et les
collectivités et un quart par les
ménages et pour être réussi la
transition écologique doit aussi se
faire avec nos concitoyens nous devons
les accompagner dans les changements à
venir et former au métier de la
transition écologique
j'ai réuni lundi un conseil national de
la transition écologique pour partager
nos objectifs secteurs par secteur et
dans le courant du mois de juin nous
serons en mesure de présenter une
planification écologique complète
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
réussir la transition écologique c'est
aussi nous adapter et anticiper tous les
cas de figure le ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires a annoncé le week-end
dernier le lancement de travaux pour
préparer la France en cas de hausse des
températures de 4 degrés que ce soit
pour réduire nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre pour nous adapter aux
effets inéluctables du dérèglement
climatique ou pour restaurer la
biodiversité nous avons besoin des
collectivités de nombreux projets
concrets se mettent en place notamment
grâce au soutien du fond vert se font ce
sont deux milliards d'euros dès cette
année et je vous confirme comme je
l'avais annoncé que se font sera
pérennisé je vous remercie merci
monsieur le Président Roquier le combat
pour le climat sera long et difficile
mais comme une équipe de rugby ne
gagnerons ou nous le perdrons tous
ensemble merci
la parole est à notre collègue Jacques
perdict pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre des
Transports Clément Beaune justement si
on veut gagner tous ensemble est-ce
vraiment le moment de saper le fret
ferroviaire public comment Monsieur le
Ministre peut-on fixer les trajectoires
du Plan Climat comment peut-on viser le
report de la route vers le rail et
accepter en même temps que Fred SNCF
l'acteur public majeur de cette
transition indispensable soit dépecée
des mots clés la Commission européenne
par sa procédure contre la France pour
être d'État soit disant illégal à Fret
SNCF mais en péril la survie même de cet
acteur essentiel à la mutation des
transports monsieur le ministre ce n'est
par des procédures technocratiques par
l'application aveugle d'une doxa
libérale que l'Europe réussira mais par
sa capacité qu'à sa capacité à
concrétiser son Green Deal à atteindre
un objectif européen 2030 du frais de
ferroviaire à 30 % de par modal la
France en est encore loin ça commence à
bouger ne laissons pas briser cet élan
entre la cause du climat et celle de la
concurrence le choix est une évidence
monsieur le ministre plutôt que de tenir
cette ligne résolue vous préférez en
prendre votre partie et consentir à en
finir avec Fret SNCF tel qu'il existe
aujourd'hui le liquidé pour lui
substituer avec deux entités une
structure assez différente pour que la
DG Concurrence admettent la
discontinuité économique comme ils
disent et donc renonce à exiger le
remboursement des aides abandons des
trains complets de 500 emplois garantit
social et salariale en danger sérieux
ouverture du capital session d'une part
des locomotives aux concurrents
renoncement aux appels d'offres pour des
années pour le trafic dédié monsieur le
ministre comment ce scénario de mise à
la découpe pourrait-il ne pas briser le
rebond ferroviaire nécessaire serez-vous
le ministre des Transports qui a liquidé
Fret SNCF
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre déléguée en charge des
transports monsieur Beaune
merci merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Fernique comme vous
je crois très fermement à l'avenir du
frais de ferroviaire et c'est une part
essentielle de notre stratégie de
planification écologique et d'ailleurs
avec le plan Fred qui est déployé depuis
maintenant deux ans nous avons inversé
une tendance historique qui était celle
du recul de la part du Fred ferroviaire
dans le transport de marchandises en
France pour la première fois depuis 2015
cette part est en train de réaugmenter
et nous ne lâcherons pas cette ambition
que nous partageons je crois tous ici
pour cela il faut en effet un opérateur
public de référence du frais de
ferroviaire et je suis bien déterminé à
le maintenir quelle est la situation
monsieur le sénateur par une faut dire
la vérité sans faciliter et sans
démagogie pour préparer l'avenir c'est
que il y a en effet une procédure qui a
été ouverte publiquement le 18 janvier
dernier par la Commission européenne
après plusieurs échanges avec la France
je me suis occupé de ces dossiers dès
mon arrivée au ministère des Transports
il y a un peu moins d'un an j'ai tout
fait nous avons tout fait du côté des
autorités françaises pour empêcher
l'ouverture procédure pour contester
comme vous venez de le faire les aides
réputées illégales sont la Commission
européenne versées pendant 15 ans par
les gouvernements successifs à fret SMCF
la procédure a été engagée et donc nous
avons aujourd'hui un choix qui est
simple et clair et que nous devons
partager soit nous disons que nous
allons en effet jusqu'au bout de cette
procédure c'est une possibilité mais
disons-le aussi très franchement le
risque est simple et c'est une quasi
certitude c'est la mort totale et cette
fois la liquidation le fret SNCF 4800
salariés et des milliers de kilomètres
aujourd'hui de rails et de Fred
ferroviaire en France je ne veux pas de
cette solution et donc oui j'assume que
en responsabilité pour ne pas mettre en
danger les femmes et les hommes du frais
de ferroviaire pour garder un groupe
public de frais de ferroviaire qui a un
avenir et que nous soutiendrons nous
devons trouver le plus rapidement
possible un accord pour mettre fin
l'incertitude et éviter la mort de cette
opérateur nous aurons un opérateur
public nous aurons un opérateur qui ne
sera pas privatisé qui gardera l'immense
majorité de ces activités sans aucun
licen ciement évidemment et sans aucun
report modal car j'y suis engagé nous
réinvestissons en même temps dans le
frais de ferroviaire de manière
totalement inédite vous amplifions
encore le plan déployé depuis 2021 pour
renforcer cette ambition
monsieur Véronique oui monsieur le
ministre vous disais ne pas vouloir
mettre en danger vous avez parlé de
jouer à la roulette russe l'avenir du
fret ferroviaire mais dans quel jeu
risqué l'engageez-vous en croyant
qu'avec une telle désorganisation les
chargeurs les acteurs économiques ne
retourneront pas à la route ne resteront
pas dans les camions
la parole est notre collègue Danny
whiteblade pour le groupe Les
Indépendants républicains
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre intérieur mes chers collègues
notre pays traverse une semaine noire
hier matin nous apprenions au décès
d'une infirmière sauvagement agressée
dimanche matin Paul m'annon Steven ont
succombé un accident du lion sinouy dans
l'exercice de leur fonction dans le Nord
ces trois policiers de moins de 25 ans
étaient au début de leur carrière et
avait toute la vie devant eux
l'un d'entre eux était pas de famille
d'un enfant de 11 mois tandis qu'un
autre allait devenir père monsieur le
ministre vous êtes venus rencontrer
leurs collègues lundi elle est nordiste
vous en remercie le groupe Les
Indépendants vers le rendre un vif
hommage et mes premières pensées vont à
l'ensemble des familles meurtri et elle
a de l'adolescente qui venait de
secourir
après la douleur
et la colère viendra le temps des
questions
on sait désormais que les deux occupants
du véhicule ayant percuté ses
fonctionnaires
sont connus pour usage stupéfiant et
d'alcool on apprend ensuite que le
chauffard conduisait sous l'emprise de
ces substances
les policiers gendarmes et pompiers ces
héros du quotidien sont de plus en plus
confrontés à des violences
insupportables et intolérable lors de
leurs interventions
comme de nombreux événements récents
nous le rappelle à chaque drame
l'émotion est plus forte
ce climat d'acidité est nourrit par le
silence assourdissant de certains
soucieux d'entretenir une atmosphère de
défiance envers les forces de l'ordre
ces femmes et ces hommes sont le garant
sont les garants de l'ordre républicain
il mérite une protection et un soutien
encore plus fort et surtout intangibles
mais il faut que la justice suive
monsieur le ministre je vous avais deux
questions quelles mesures attendez-vous
prendre afin de soutenir et de compagner
les familles des victimes dans cette
période
pouvez nous dire comment le gouvernement
entend poursuivre son action pour
soutenir nos forces de sécurité
intérieure contre les multiples menaces
auxquelles elles sont confrontées
pour vous répondre
la parole des tomates Sonia baquet
secrétaire d'été en charge de la
citoyenneté
monsieur le sénateur
effectivement vous l'avez dit le métier
les métiers de policier gendarme sont
des métiers de plus en plus difficiles
eu égard aux exigences légitimes de nos
concitoyens et au risque et aux menaces
qui pèsent sur eux
ils ont besoin de tout notre souci
pardon et à ce titre je me joins aux
hommages qui ont été rendus à
l'Assemblée nationale et ici même et par
la première ministre aux trois policiers
qui sont décédés la semaine dernière
dans l'exercice de leurs fonctions
depuis le 1er janvier dernier ce sont
2380 gendarmes et policiers qui ont été
blessés dans l'exercice de leur fonction
et on peut souligner
ce policier blessé lors de la
manifestation du 1er mai par un cocktail
Molotov et tous ceux qui ont été blessés
dans le cadre des manifestations qui ont
eu lieu ces dernières semaines
le Parlement a voté la loopmie et il
m'appartient de vous remercier qui a
doté la police et la gendarmerie de
moyens exceptionnels des moyens humains
et budgétaires d'abord avec 15 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires et des moyens
statutaires qui permettent de valoriser
de mieux prendre en compte la carrière
de nos de nos militaires de nos
gendarmes et de nos policiers nous
entendons bien évidemment et c'est
l'objet de votre question pour suivre
nos efforts pour mieux protéger les
policiers les gendarmes c'est déjà en
cours de déploiement puisque ce sont des
caméras piétons qui sont développées qui
sont déployés pardon dans tous les
commissariats c'est une protection
fonctionnelle qui est facilité c'est une
cellule d'assistance aux policiers
victimes qui a été créé en 2021 et c'est
de nouveau de nouveaux équipements qui
lui permettent leur protection physique
avec des casques lourds des casques
pardon et des gilets lourds
nous avons également grâce au soutien du
Parlement créé le délit spécifique
de violences volontaires sur argent sur
argent pardon chargé de la sécurité
intérieure et de protection des agents
en bord de route la locmi a également
créé 20 postes de psychologues qui
permet pardon d'accompagner au mieux les
policiers et les gendarmes le ministre
de l'intérieur est très attentif à la
protection des forces de sécurité
intérieure avec l'aide du Parlement je
vous remercie
la parole est à notre collègue Christine
lavard pour le groupe les républicains
monsieur le ministre 2023 mois de mars
avec la plus faible natalité depuis 1994
2022 année avec la plus faible fécondité
depuis 1946 pourquoi les Français
ont-ils moins d'enfants on pourrait
penser à l'éco-xiété on pourrait surtout
penser aux problèmes du logement cela
fait des mois que les élus locaux vous
alertent sur la crise du logement et
pourtant le Conseil national de la
refondation consacrée à ce sujet a été
reporté cinédié il devait se tenir le 9
mai on pourrait penser au manque de
moyens financiers sous François Hollande
le quotient familial les allocations
familiales ont diminué sous Emmanuel
Macron les allocations familiales ont
été faiblement revalorisées la CMG a
diminué alors que les 1000 premiers
jours alors que il existe des excédents
la branche famille 1,9 milliards
d'excédents 2022 après 2,9 milliards en
2021 5,8 milliards d'erreurs comptables
le constat est sévère la sentence sans
appel la cour des comptes a de valider
les comptes de la branche famille pour
2022 mais aussi difficulté à faire
garder les enfants de moins de 3 ans
alors que les 1000 premiers jours
avaient été érigés comme une priorité
aucune des préconisations du rapport
spirulique n'a trouvé une traduction
législative ou réglementaire la
conférence des familles de 2022 annonce
un droit opposable à la garde pour 2027
un rapport de ligase du 11 avril dernier
dénonce la baisse de la qualité
d'accueil la restitution du CNR petite
enfance prévue au mois de mars reporté
elle aussi cinédiée la cause la future
coche est toujours en cours de
discussion elle sera donc connue des
acteurs avec au moins plus de trois mois
de retard le constat est sombre alors
Monsieur le Ministre qu'allez-vous
proposer au président de la République
qui semble enfin s'inquiéter des
chiffres alarmants de la natalité
pour vous répondre la parole est homélie
des solidarités
de l'autonomie personne handicapée
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice lavable vous abordez plusieurs
questions dans votre question je
voudrais revenir d'abord sur la question
de la non certification des comptes par
la Cour des comptes des comptes 2022 de
la branche famille de la sécurité
sociale qui nous interroge à la fois sur
les difficultés qui ont pu conduire à
cette non certification qui remet pas en
question d'ailleurs la bonne tenue des
comptes de la branche mais qui dénonce à
certains nombre de problématiques en
matière de contrôle interne de la
branche auquel nous verrons à remédier à
la fois en travaillant sur la
sécurisation du système avec le projet
de solidarité à la source pour veiller à
une meilleure versement des prestations
sociales à une simplification en luttant
contre le non recours en limitant contre
la fraude et en luttant contre les indus
dans la branche et vous abordez une
deuxième question qui est celle de la
question de la natalité dans notre pays
alors vous le savez le taux de natalité
aujourd'hui proche de 1,8 enfants par
femme c'est un taux de natalité qui est
en forte baisse et qui ne permet pas le
renouvellement des générations dans
notre pays qui doit tous nous inquiéter
parce que il pose un certain nombre de
problèmes notamment il fait peser sur
notre système de protection sociale des
tensions qui sont extrêmement fortes et
donc mon rôle en tant que ministre des
familles et de la petite enfance c'est
aussi bien de répondre aujourd'hui à
l'envie des familles de pouvoir avoir
des enfants dans notre pays puisque on
sait que le désir d'enfant et d'environ
2,4 enfants par femme ce que nous nous
pensons c'est que avant de penser
augmenter les prestations ou les
allocations familiales pour pouvoir
favoriser ce voilà cette réponse à ce
désir d'enfant c'est d'abord d'améliorer
les services aux familles et comme vous
l'avez dit l'une des premières
préoccupations aujourd'hui des familles
dans notre pays c'est de savoir comment
elles vont pouvoir faire garder leur
enfant on le sait il manquerait environ
200 000 places d'accueil
du jeune enfant le président de la
République s'est engagé à mettre en
place ce service public de la petite
enfance la première ministre aura des
annonces dans les jours qui viennent
pour vous dire comment nous répondrons à
cette question
merci
[Musique]
proposé pour autant des idées nous nous
en avons par exemple prendre en compte
la taille des logements familiaux dans
la comptabilisation SRU supprimer la
modulation des allocations familiales
supprimer la tarification horaires de la
PSU qui est complexe et qui engendre
nombre de Ford donner un véritable
pouvoir de sanction au PMI monsieur le
ministre à chaque enfant qui naît le
monde recommence une politique familiale
ambitieuse et la meilleure réforme des
retraites vous disposez de 6 milliards
pour financer cette politique merci
[Musique]
la parole est à notre collègue Stéphane
de Milly pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur je souhaite vous parler d'un
sujet de fond très grave mais
permettez-moi de le faire par le biais
d'une rhétorique un peu inhabituelle
celle d'une charade une charade
intitulée je fais ce que je veux quand
je veux comme je veux et où je veux mon
premier est une manifestation dite
musicale interdite par deux arrêtés
préfectoraux mon deuxième a réuni malgré
l'état de droit dans lequel nous vivons
plus de 30000 personnes dans un petit
village de l'Indre qui a subitement vu
sa population multipliée par 273 pour
devenir l'espace d'un long weekend la
capitale de la race party
mon troisième malgré la mobilisation de
320 gendarmes c'est soldé par plus de
500 prises en charge par les services de
secours dont 30 évacués en urgence
absolue mon quatrième à générer 15
tonnes de déchets dans le terrain privé
d'un propriétaire qui a vu converger en
quelques heures sans en être averti une
marée humaine de tueur et mon tout
monsieur le ministre apporte de l'eau
moules de ceux qui s'inquiètent du
délitement de l'autorité de l'État
monsieur le ministre cet épisode du
teknival est loin d'être isolé d'autres
départements y compris le mien ayant dû
subir cette dictature de l'urgence et de
la masse je sais bien comme le rappeler
Machiavel que le choix est rarement
entre le bien et le mal mais entre le
pire et le moindre mal mais j'ai
néanmoins deux questions à vous poser à
propos de cet épisode affligent
la première est peut-être naïve mais
comment se fait-il que tout le monde
était au courant de ce rassemblement
sauf ceux qui devaient l'être ma
deuxième question est d'ordre
pragmatique pour dissuader ce genre
d'événements illégaux et dangereux sans
parler de l'alcool et de la drogue ne
faut-il pas durcir les sanctions contre
les organisateurs qui aujourd'hui
individuellement ne risque rien si ce
n'est 1500 euros d'amende monsieur le
ministre ces images de temps de
désinvolture ont une résonance terrible
dans l'opinion publique mais je pense
que vous le savez
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
secrétaire d'État en charge de la
citoyenneté madame baquet
vous nous interrogez sur le
rassemblement festif musical du 17 mai
dernier baptisé technival French tech
2023 et comme vous l'avez dit il a été
non déclaré aucune demande
d'autorisation n'a été faite les
renseignements territoriaux puisque
c'est votre première question avait bien
identifié l'organisation en cours d'une
manifestation de ce type dans le centre
de la France mais et vous le savez aussi
le lieu exact a été défini quelques
heures avant le rassemblement et ce sont
en quelques heures jusqu'à 25000
personnes qui se sont réunies sur le
site et dans l'urgence ont été organisés
cet événement pardon alors que et vous
l'avez dit les conditions ne s'y
prêtaient absolument pas ni d'un point
de vue sanitaire ni d'un point de vue de
la sécurité sous l'autorité du préfet et
en urgence et je veux remercier les
services de l'État qui se sont rendus
disponibles et rendus extrêmement
efficace pour accompagner cette
manifestation les moyens de la
préfecture des services de l'État ont
été mis en place les services du
département avec notamment la
mobilisation des sapeurs-pompiers et des
associations de sécurité civile le
préfet a coordonné un dispositif
opérationnel pour garantir l'ordre
public avec succès et pour garantir
d'éviter la circulation de festivaliers
qui sortait sous l'emprise de l'alcool
nous avons renforcé les moyens de
manière significative vous avez parlé de
320 gendarmes se sont 434 gendarmes qui
ont été mobilisés sur l'opération pour
empêcher tout trouble majeur à l'ordre
public et nous pouvons je crois tous
ensemble souligner le bilan de
l'opération avec
30200 personnes et 13300 voitures qui
ont été contrôlées 155 verbalisations
pour conduite en état débriété 32
verbalisations pour stupéfiants la
saisie de 300 g de cannabis d'un kilo
d'herbe de cannabis de 40 g de cocaïne
etc etc nous avons également saisi les
groupes électrogènes et les
organisateurs pour la plupart ont été
identifiés les procédures sont en cours
et ils seront bien évidemment
sanctionnés je vous remercie
monsieur
la parole de notre collègue Michel Gréau
pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen et écologiste
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de
l'économie voilà plus de 60 jours que
des salariés de Vertbaudet dans le Nord
sont en grève pour rappel cette usine
est composée majoritairement de femmes
l'entreprise Verbaudet est l'une des 59
entités détenues par le fond
d'investissement et kyston a fond de
dimension européenne l'examen du bilan
financier de l'entreprise était
différent entre 2018 et 2021 la marge
net est passée de - 0,7% à plus de
3,6%. la valeur ajoutée de 49,7 millions
à 56,6 millions d'euros et sur la même
période la part des salaires par rapport
au chiffre d'affaires et passer de 15,6%
à
12,1%. l'unique revendication de ses
salariés est une augmentation de salaire
de 150 euros tous les chiffres montrent
que cette revendication est légitime
actuellement l'inflation les rattrapes
et les fins de mois sont difficiles
depuis deux mois pas de dialogue avec la
direction des propos sexistes à leur
égard intervention des forces de police
intimidation à la menace de licenciement
tout y passe les salariés sont
déterminés et leur lutte devient
emblématique les salaires dans
l'entreprise varient entre 1300 et 1500
euros mensuels malgré leur ancienneté
quand le dirigeant perçoit une
rémunération de 60000 euros par mois
cette grève met en lumière une question
centrale comment faire ses choix de vie
sans un salaire digne comment être
véritablement libre sans indépendance
économique la solidarité le soutien de
tout le monde du travail s'exprime y
compris financièrement et quelques par
cette lutte est devenue celle de tous
les salariés du pays par procuration
monsieur le mille et le ministre vous
prétendez appeler au partage de la
valeur n'y a-t-il pas avec Vertbaudet
une belle occasion de sa mise en oeuvre
merci
pour vous répondre la parole des
communistes du travail plein d'emploi
d'une insertion monsieur dufe
merci monsieur le Président merci
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
mesdames la sénatrice vous évoquez le
conflit social en cours au sein de
l'entreprise Vertbaudet plus
particulièrement dans l'établissement
situé dans votre département
ce conflit social est bien connu des
services de mon ministère et de mon
cabinet il a été ouvert autour du 20
mars et un accord a été signé un accord
majoritaire sur lequel vous pouvez avoir
une appréciation signée par deux
organisations syndicales Force ouvrière
et la CFE-CGC en soulignant que ces deux
organisations représentent lors des
dernières consultations 63% des
suffrages exprimés dans l'entreprise la
CGT n'a pas souhaité signer cet accord
et à laisser le mouvement se poursuivre
et encourager sa poursuite del 9 avril
les services de la Direction
Départementale de l'économie de l'emploi
du travail de la solidarité ont initié
une médiation cette médiation s'est
traduite par une première décision de
l'entreprise en l'occurrence 30
embauches 30 recrutements de personnels
en intérim dont
la mission d'intérim a été transformée
en contrat de travail à durée
indéterminé le 1er mai dernier l'accord
qui a été conclu fin mars prévoit une
augmentation de la rémunération mais il
est vrai pas par une voie salariale par
la mise en oeuvre de prime et d'autres
modalités de rémunération depuis depuis
il y a un certain nombre de contacts qui
ont été initiés et mon cabinet a
notamment permis un échange et un
rapprochement entre le cabinet de la
secrétaire général de la CGT madame
Guinée et la direction générale de
l'entreprise une réunion c'est à nouveau
tenue lundi dernier il y a trois jours
avec des propositions nouvelles de la
direction que la CGT a un nouveau refusé
alors nous parlons il y a environ 70
salariés sur les 340 que compte le site
qui sont toujours en grève d'autres sont
d'autres réunions sont prévues je
souhaite évidemment que le dialogue
social permette cet aboutissement dans
le respect des prérogatifs de sac chacun
dans le respect aussi de l'accord
majoritaire qui a été signé il y a
maintenant quelques semaines je termine
d'un mot monsieur le Président pour dire
que madame la sénatrice a évoqué
l'intervention de la police pour
enlever et faire ôter les points de
grève les piquets de grève cette
intervention de la police à la demande
du préfet de région a été faite en
application une ordonnance rendue par le
tribunal saisi par l'entreprise il y a
plusieurs semaines
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Michel Dagbert pour le groupe du
Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants
si on s'adresse au ministre chargé des
transports Clément bonne et porte sur le
fret ferroviaire comme quoi dans cette
émission on peut poser deux fois la même
question mais sous un prisme différent
subissant la forte concurrence de la
route la part du rail dans le transport
de marchandises n'a cessé de diminuer
durant ces dernières décennies elle est
ainsi divisée par deux entre 2006 et
2019 pour passer de 20 à 10%. c'est un
fait c'est une réalité les avantages du
frais de ferroviaire sont pourtant
indéniables faisant de celui-ci un
formidable outil de la décarbonation des
activités économiques un train de
marchandises équivaut à 40 camions ils
réalisent près de 10 fois moins
d'émissions de CO2 et consomment 6 fois
moins d'énergie à la tonne transportée
que le mode routier ça aussi c'est un
fait le Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures dans ces différents
rapports a d'ailleurs souligné
l'importance qu'il y avait à le
développer aussi le gouvernement a
affiché à plusieurs reprises sa volonté
et vous l'avez rappelé monsieur
féministe de soutenir le transport de
marchandises par le rail l'objectif d'un
doublement de la part modale du Fred DC
2030 a été inscrit dans la loi climat et
résilience du 22 août 2021 de plus une
stratégie nationale pour le
développement du Fred ferroviaire
comportant 72 mesures a été présentée et
170 millions d'aides supplémentaires par
an ont été alloués ce soutien
additionnel sera prolongé jusqu'en 2027
dans ce contexte les difficultés
rencontrées par la filiale de Fred de la
SNCF en effet inquiète puisque la
Commission européenne et ça a été
rappelée a démarré une procédure en
janvier aussi je sais l'investissement
qui est le vote monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous annoncer
les mesures que vous avez annoncé hier
et nous dire le calendrier de la mise en
œuvre de ce dispositif visant à faire
perdurer le fret SNCF et à rassurer ses
salariés
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégués chargés les transports
monsieur bonne
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Dagbert je le redis nous vivons
une situation difficile au regard de
cette procédure engagée par la
Commission européenne et je leur ai
affirme parce que le sujet d'une grande
gravité je ne ferai pas le choix de la
facilité qui consisterait simplement à
passer le dossier au suivant et à verser
dans quelques mois ou quelques années
des larmes de crocodile sur l'entreprise
qu'on aurait laissé mourir par démagogie
et donc je veux régler cette situation
aujourd'hui d'ici la fin de l'année pour
répondre très précisément à votre
question par un accord oui un accord
exigeant avec des lignes rouges très
précises évidemment la préservation
intégrale de l'emploi aucun licenciement
et la préservation dans un opérateur
public ferroviaire dans l'avenir est
viable de plus de 90% des effectifs
actuels je crois que c'est une mesure
très importante sans aucune
privatisation il est évident qu'il doit
y avoir un capital public au sein d'un
groupe ferroviaire qui est celui de la
SNCF et sans aucun report modal car vous
avez rappelé les avantages du frais de
ferroviaire nous en sommes convaincus et
en train de Fred c'est l'équivalent de
40 camions c'est 10 fois moins
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre nous
sommes le gouvernement qui a enfin
redressé la part du Fred ferroviaire en
France nous continuerons cela est-ce que
je propose ce n'est pas une solution du
moindre mal ça n'est pas un avenir au
rabais c'est un avenir sérieux et
positif pour le frais de ferroviaire
public et privé en France car nous
aurons besoin de beaucoup d'opérateurs
pour développer ce mode de transport et
c'est pour cela que nous avons annoncé
sous l'autorité de la première ministre
un plan amplifié et accéléré pour le
fret 200 millions d'euros seront alloués
dès la fin de l'année prochaine pour
l'aide au wagon isolé pour les aides à
l'exploitation pour les opérateurs de
fret notamment l'opérateur de Fred
ferroviaire public c'est une visibilité
donnée jusqu'à 2030 pour garantir les
investissements et le redressement de la
part du Fred ferroviaire en France dans
les contrats de plombs et ta région ce
seront 2 milliards d'euros qui seront
mobilisés en investissement 4 fois
supérieur à celui que nous avons vécu
sur la période précédente de contrat de
plan est à région pour investir dans le
garde de triage pour investir nos lignes
de fret c'est un effort qui n'a jamais
été fait dans notre pays et que nous
prolongerons de 2 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires jusqu'au début de la
décennie prochaine c'est donc un effort
dans la durée un effort sérieux je ne
veux pas qu'on vive dans l'incertitude
je veux qu'on prépare l'avenir avec les
salariés du frais de ferroviaire public
français
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Martin filleul pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
merci monsieur le Président je
souhaitais à mon tour rendre hommage aux
trois policiers de Roubaix décédé dans
l'exercice de leur fonction j'ai une
pensée pour leur famille à laquelle je
sais s'associer l'ensemble de cette
émission monsieur le ministre depuis
deux mois les 72 salariés de Verbaudet
demande à pouvoir vivre dignement du
fruit de leur travail pour beaucoup des
femmes en grève pour la première fois de
leur vie face aux rechutes de la
direction d'augmenter les salaires un
compromis dans la douleur a été trouvé
0% d'augmentation salariale mais des
primes des socialisés le délégué CFDT le
dit très clairement c'était cela ou rien
le 0% on l'a très mal vécu alors grévist
ou non personne ne peut trouver normal
qu'après 20 ans de boîte les salaires
plafonnent au SMIC au moment où tout
augmente je partage l'inquiétude de ces
femmes salariées
grande perdante de la réforme des
retraites de ne pas voir abonder leurs
pensions avec ses primes face à un
blocage de cette nature la réponse ne
peut être celle de l'intimidation et de
la violence mais Verbaudet n'est qu'un
exemple parmi d'autres durant la période
du covid vous nous expliquer la main sur
le cœur qu'il n'y a qu'il n'y aurait un
avant et un après pour les travailleurs
de première ligne alors allez-vous
continuer à dresser des vœux pieux au
patronat à coups de demandes ou bien
allez-vous enfin endosser le rôle d'un
État qui m'est réellement en pratique le
partage juste de la valeur on se plaçant
au côté des travailleurs
pour vous répondre la parole de
communiste du travail Duprès de l'emploi
de l'insertion monsieur du stop
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice filleul je complète les propos
que j'ai tenus il y a quelques instants
réponse madame la signatrice Riom mais
peut-être pour évoquer deux points
premier point vous avez parlé
d'intimidation et violence et je suppose
que vous faites référence
à l'agression qui a subi un des délégués
CGT de l'entreprise en question le
délégué en question était reçu par les
représentants de la préfecture et il lui
a été vivement conseillé vous l'imaginez
de déposer plainte à l'heure où je
m'exprime devant vous et à ma
connaissance cela n'a pas été fait et il
est responsable de la Préfecture se sont
même heurtés à un refus de dépôt de
plantes vous évoquez madame la sénatrice
l'accord intervenu à la fin du mois de
mars je vous confirme et vous en
connaissez la teneur que cet accord
prévoit une prime à hauteur de 650 euros
de mémoire ainsi qu'un certain nombre de
dispositions relatives à la rémunération
sans qu'il y ait d'évolution salariale
particulière
vous dites l'État doit jouer son rôle
nous le faisons dans le respect du prix
des prérogatives des acteurs du dialogue
social à la fois par immédiation locale
par une intervention toujours sous forme
de médiation et de prise de contact
intervention qui s'est traduite par la
réunion que j'ai évoquée il y a un
instant qui s'est tenu avant-hier qui
n'a pas débouché sur un accord je l'ai
dit à madame la sénatrice Réole à
l'heure nous parlons 72 des presque 350
salariés de Vertbaudet sont en grève et
maintiennent leur mouvement de grève une
réunion doit se tenir en toute fin de
semaine je pense qu'un centre de
propositions seront faites et j'espère
seront de nature à avancer dans la
résolution de ce conflit mais nous
sommes face à une situation particulière
et je sais que vous entendrez je crois
en tout cas cet argument vous nous
demandez d'intervenir finalement pour
décider à la place de celles et ceux qui
sont chargés du dialogue social
l'employeur et les organisations
syndicales il y a une décision vous
pouvez porter une appréciation négative
sur l'accord intervenu à la fin du mois
de mars mais cet accord vous le savez
est considéré et à juste titre comme
majoritaire puisque signé par des
organisations syndicales représentant
63% des salariés concernés
sur le ministre de votre réponse qui ne
me satisfait que partiellement car
au-delà de l'exemple de Vertbaudet et
des volontés de négociations et bien il
y a une situation nationale qui se pose
celle de la politique salariale les
Français veulent pouvoir vivre dignement
de leur travail et aujourd'hui je
regrette que votre gouvernement ne soit
pas au rendez-vous de cette attente des
Français je vous remercie
la parole est à notre collègue Henri
Leroy pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre en 2022 près de 500
000 migrants légaux sont entrés en
France établissant un record absolu à
cela il faut il faut ajouter les
immigrés illégaux plus de 300000 selon
les estimations de Frontex les chèques
du gouvernement a contrôlé l'immigration
et pas tant le coût économique de cette
immigration est un sujet que le nom peut
plus éluder l'aide médicale d'État
continue de progresser de plus de 12%
cette année pour atteindre un point
culminant à 1,2 milliards d'euros et
l'accueil des immigrés pèsent de plus en
plus sur nos finances publiques le coût
social de l'Immigration et de moins en
moins acceptable la loi n'est pas
respectée les auqtf ne sont pas exécutés
sans oublier le communautarisme et la
violence qui congrennent notre société
touchant bien souvent les Français les
plus modestes
des solutions existent pour reprendre le
contrôle de l'immigration certains pays
comme le Danemark nous démontre qu'il
n'y a pas de fatalité mais encore
faut-il en avoir la volonté l'excellent
rapport du signateur buffet nous manque
d'ailleurs la voie en le domaine des
propositions concrètes ont été faites
par les républicains et deux
propositions de loi dont une
constitutionnelle offre de nouvelles
perspectives madame la Première ministre
la France va mal et vous regardez
ailleurs vous préférez temporiser en
adoptant une approche durant même temps
cher au président de la République
madame la Première ministre ma question
est simple quand allez-vous ouvrir les
yeux sur le drame qui se joue sous vos
yeux et vous emparé sérieusement de ce
sujet
pour vous répondre la parole
au ministre de l'intérieur des Outre-mer
monsieur Gérald Darmanin
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Leroy comme vous nous sommes
évidemment préoccupés par les questions
migratoires comme partout en Europe 60%
de demandeurs d'asile par exemple se
sont présentés à nos frontières et tous
les pays vous l'avez constaté quel que
soit les régimes politiques quel que
soit d'ailleurs le choix qu'ils ont fait
en matière migratoire ont les mêmes
difficultés je vous ferai un remarquer
quand même c'était pas dans votre
question que depuis le début de l'année
il y a moins de demandes d'asile
aujourd'hui qui en a eu depuis les trois
dernières années contrairement à ce qui
se passe chez de voisins européens
puisqu'on est à 110 000 demandes d'asile
en moyenne sur le mois d'avril et
deuxièmement nous avons augmenté
l'exécution des eqtf et les laisser
passer consulaire de plus de 20% depuis
le 1er janvier alors vous évoquez des
propositions nous sommes évidemment
heureux de les entendre nous n'avons pas
encore vu les deux textes se proposer
par les LR nous avons compris qu'il nous
est pas totalement consensus avec les
centrist du Sénat qui vont déposer
eux-mêmes je crois des textes nous nous
sommes là monsieur monsieur le sénateur
pour discuter avec l'ensemble de
l'échiquier politique et singulièrement
avec la majorité seattoriale puisque
nous avons déposé un texte et vous avez
déjà commencé à étudier en commission
dans les propositions DLR que nous avons
lu ce weekend il y a des choses tout à
fait concordantes la fin de la fin de la
double peine par exemple pour les
étrangers délinquants l'intégration
obligatoire par l'apprentissage du
français la simplification du droit
c'est-à-dire le rapport buffet nous
avons évidemment beaucoup de convergence
il y a aussi des différences monsieur
sénateur et notamment des divergences de
principes sur lesquels sans doute il
faut que nous débattions vous proposez
pour certaines dispositions de sortir de
la Convention de Genève de 1951 de
sortir des traités de l'Union européenne
de sortir du Conseil de l'Europe de
sortir de la CEDH et si c'est tout à
fait vrai c'est une question importante
que ce frexit migratoire il faut
évidemment que nous puissions échanger
sur les propositions constitutionnelles
mais avouez que c'est ici nous faisons
un projet de loi ordinaire je veux
redire que à la demande de la première
ministre j'ai entrepris les nég
ociations les discussions avec le groupe
LR du Sénat avec les centrist avec tous
les autres groupes qui le souhaitent
bien évidemment pour je l'espère à
l'automne discuter de ce texte arrêté
d'en parler et de commencer d'être
concret comme vous l'a proposé le
gouvernement
monsieur Leroy
oui monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
nous savons vous êtes un homme d'écoute
et que vous nous entendrez mais ma
question s'adressait à madame la
Première ministre
cette Français sur dix dénonce le trop
plein d'immigrés en France ils ont ces
Français des difficultés pour ce soigner
pour s'alimenter et pour vivre décemment
dans un climat d'insécurité ou la
violence devient quotidienne alors
madame la Première ministre donnez-leur
un peu d'espoir et agissez merci
la parole est notre collègue Angel prévu
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ce seront
les divers responsables de la ruine de
la terre qui organiseront le sauvetage
du peu qui en restera et qui après
l'abondance gèreront la pénurie et la
survie voilà ce que prophétisé le
penseur Bernard Charbonneau il y a 40
ans plus 4 degrés Celsius c'est quand
même la catastrophe annoncée sans aucune
adaptation possible tout le littoral
français sous l'eau des vagues de
chaleur bien au-delà des 42°c auquel
tout le monde ne pourra pas survivre des
sécheresses sévères des pénuridaux des
pertes de récolte notre modèle est en
cause le perpétuer alors qu'il se heurte
assez limite relève d'un déni
impardonnable notre lutte contre la
crise climatique doit s'intensifier car
elle va générer des dommages colossaux
qui n'en est pas conscient votre mantra
pas d'impôt pas de taxe nous mène dans
l'impasse nous devons faire en disant ce
que nous n'avons pas fait en 30 dit le
rapport de Jean Pisani Ferri qui n'est
pourtant pas un dangereux et coteau écho
terroristes et qui propose entre autres
solutions de lever un impôt sur les 10%
les plus aisés pour financer la
transition écologique à vrai dire il n'y
a rien d'extravagant à imaginer qu'il
contribue à cet effort à la hauteur de
leur moyen en effet changer sa chaudière
et acquérir une voiture électrique n'est
pas à la portée de tous les Français et
pourtant la réduction conséquente en gaz
à effet de serre et donc l'habitabilité
de la planète profiteront à tous une
répartition équitable et non seulement
la moindre des choses mais relève d'une
justice sociale absolument indispensable
pour emporter l'adhésion et
l'acceptabilité de tous nous avons cessé
depuis 2017 de vous proposer des mesures
fortes comme justement l'instauration
d'un ISF climatique en pure perte
comment envisagez-vous les financements
nécessaires au changement radical qui
s'impose à nous
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste de la transition écologique
et de la cohésion des territoires
Mitsubishi
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Préville
le rapport Pisani ferrique commandé par
le gouvernement il traite de beaucoup de
choses sur les 156 pages je note que
vous vous concentrez sur les trois qui
concernent la fiscalité vous auriez pu
souligner qu'il insiste sur la cohérence
de la stratégie de planification portée
portée par la première ministre et en
citant très exactement cette phrase du
rapport Pisany ferries et c'est le
mamafous disant qu'il nous faut faire en
disant ce que nous n'avons pas fait en
30 ans c'est en fait une citation
d'Elisabeth borne qui date d'octobre
dernier au moment du lancement du CNR
sur le climat et la biodiversité
je tiens à juste rappeler une ou deux
choses simples
dans ce domaine dans ce domaine
chacun serait bien inspiré d'insister
sur la hauteur de la marche sur le
chemin qui nous reste à parcourir plutôt
que de donner le sentiment que certains
avaient la solution parce que la vérité
c'est que depuis qu'il n'y a plus
d'écologistes au gouvernement le rythme
de baisse des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre à doubler
et une partie de ceux qui parlent passé
étaient les plus activistes et les plus
radicaux et qui nous incitait à sortir
du nucléaire à l'époque serait
aujourd'hui responsable si les
gouvernements successifs les avaient
écoutés d'une hausse des émissions qui
nous aurait considérablement éloigné de
là où nous en sommes aujourd'hui en
terme d'empreinte alors dans ce domaine
il y a à la fois un plan une stratégie
double l'atténuation présenter lundi
l'adaptation qui est nécessaire et qui
pour le coup ne dit un déni ni à
renoncement mais juste une manière de
regarder ensemble le fait que la
trajectoire n'est pas la bonne maille la
question du financement elle ne peut pas
être tabou mais dans la manière dont
elle est traitée par Monsieur Pisani
Ferri elle évoque plusieurs pistes
d'abord faire en sorte de réorienter les
dépenses nous sommes dans les champions
du monde en termes de prélèvement
obligatoire l'écologie ne doit pas être
le prétexte pour augmenter les impôts il
faut réorienter des dépenses et
réorienter de la fiscalité mais en aucun
cas ne se servir de ce prétexte pour
aller ajouter à une forme d'écologie qui
écartera une partie de nos concitoyens
alors qu'on a besoin de tout le monde
pour réussir compte tenu de l'ampleur du
défi
madame Préville
merci monsieur le ministre pour votre
réponse mais on ne peut pas se
satisfaire de la situation quelle que
soit ce qui a été engagé et c'est vrai
qu'il y a des choses qui ont été
engagées mais nous avons des inquiétudes
notamment sur les nations récurrentes
pour inaction climatique pour non
respect de la qualité de l'air sur des
paroles sur la pose environnementale par
exemple et sur très concrètement dans
les différentes lois des régressions
environnementales je crois
qu'effectivement je suis d'accord avec
vous mais sur ce que vous avez dit sauf
sur le fait que c'est une des parties de
la solution dont on ne peut pas se
passer le fait de d'avoir un petit peu
plus de justice sociale et notamment sur
l'acceptabilité
la parole est à notre collègue Nadine
belureau pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Intérieur la
commune de villegongies dans l'Indre 120
habitants a dû accueillir 30 000 tefeurs
à l'occasion du 30e technique il est
compréhensible que les jeunes se
retrouvent pour écouter de la musique
mais il est inacceptable que ce soit en
violation du droit de la propriété
inacceptable que ce soit en
contradiction avec un arrêté préfectoral
en l'absence d'organisateurs non
identifiables et non d'identifier en
l'absence tout simplement d'organisation
c'est donc la collectivité dont son
ensemble qui organisé la sécurité
physique et sanitaire des festivaliers
et de la population je veux saluer et
remercier les sapeurs-pompiers de
l'Indre les associations de la
protection civile les gendarmes les
équipes du Samu le personnel de santé
les services de l'État les collectivités
pour leur mobilisation
24 heures sur 24 durant cinq jours tout
cela a un coût et c'est le contribuable
qui paiera même si et on peut le saluer
des confiscations ont eu lieu et c'est
heureux mais au-delà du financier il est
urgent monsieur le ministre de
réinstaurer un cadre juridique ferme qui
permet d'anticiper et de responsabiliser
les festivaliers comme cela était le cas
avant 2016 l'île l'égalité entretient la
clandestinité et les festivals
continueront il existe depuis 30 ans
alors Monsieur le Ministre quelle mesure
comptez-vous prendre pour mettre fin à
l'impuissance de l'État devant ces
situations merci pour vous répondre la
parole est au ministre de l'intérieur
des Outre-mer monsieur Gérald Darmanin
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
sénateurs madame la sénatrice bellurault
merci d'abord des propos que vous êtes
nus pour les services publics qui soient
départementaux et locaux mais bien sûr
qui concerne les gendarmes et
singulièrement le préfet je sais qui
était mobilisé je l'ai de très
nombreuses fois au téléphone et ses
équipes préfectorales puisque vous avez
parfaitement raison il y a eu violation
du droit de propriété par plus de 30000
personnes dans votre département un
rassemblement qui n'était pas déclaré
dès que nous avons eu quelques heures
avant l'information qui se rejoindrait
sur le site que vous avez évoqué dans
cette commune dont je voudrais
évidemment saluer les élus municipaux et
l'engagement qu'ils ont pu avoir malgré
les difficultés que vous avez dites et
les nuisances extrêmement fortes un
arrêté a été pris par Monsieur préfet
mais quand il y a 30000 personnes et
notamment des très jeunes gens qui se
rendent sur ce site j'ai pris la
responsabilité madame la sédatrice de ne
pas demander l'évacuation par la force
de ces jeunes qui avaient entre 15 et 30
ans pour la plupart d'entre eux et qui
évidemment dans ces conditions aurait pu
connaître mais je pense que la
protection de la jeunesse allait même
avant malheureusement les nuisances
inacceptables que l'on a constaté nous
avons en revanche décidé de contrôler
l'intégralité des personnes et vous
savez qu'il y a eu plus de 30000
contrôles vous l'avez dit vous mais
vous-même madame la sénatrice je vous
récidire que
13363 véhicules ont été entièrement
contrôlés faisant d'être un millier de
verbalisations ou d'interpellations pour
consommation de stupéfiants et où
consommation d'alcool que de très
nombreux toutes sortes de drogues ont
été saisis et je veux évidemment aussi
souligner que le préfet a fait des
articles 40 pour que bien sûr il puisse
y avoir poursuit après constitution de
qui est responsable de cette situation
et qui est l'organisateur de ces fêtes
dont on pense madame la sénatrice vous
et moi qu'il y a beaucoup d'argent
derrière tout ça également c'est sûr que
le droit actuel ne nous permet pas dans
les circonstances que vous avez évoqué
de pouvoir poursuivre les organisateurs
qui ne se déclarent pas il faut que nous
travaillons sans doute avec le Sénat
comme nous le faisons sur d'autres
sujets je pense évidemment aux personnes
qui s'installe légalement sur les aires
d'accueil ou les non heures d'accueil et
il y a des propositions de la part du
Sénat le gouvernement les regardera avec
intérêt en lien avec le ministre des
collectivités locales Christophe Béchu
madame belureau
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
ministre vous dit prêt au dialogue pour
pouvoir travailler sur cette question je
le redis en effet il faut prévoir à
l'avance des terrains adaptés à ces
rassemblements car gouverner sait
prévoir et il faut absolument que l'on
puisse ne puisse être de nouveau
confronté à une situation comme celle-ci
c'est-à-dire devant le fait accompli
la parole de notre collègue Nadia sur le
groupe sur le groupe de l'Union
centriste
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Agriculture mes chers
collègues la Cour des comptes a rendu
lundi un rapport sur l'avenir de
l'élevage bovin qui a causé sur tous les
bancs de vivre et actions et j'associe à
la mienne mes collègues Nathalie Goulet
Anne-Catherine Loisier et tous ceux qui
sont élus dans des terres d'élevage
bovin c'est-à-dire beaucoup le rend
Duplomb vous a interpellé hier sur ce
sujet et vous lui avez répondu que vous
feriez fermement le choix de la
souveraineté nationale en la matière
mais le rapport en question préconise
clairement ceci mangez moins de viande
produire moins de viande et être ainsi à
l'équilibre et de cette manière en fait
on assume la souveraineté alors
pouvez-vous me confirmer monsieur le
ministre que c'est plus que vous voulez
pour l'élevage bovin que cette filière
d'excellence reste également
exportatrice conserve des capacités de
production supérieures à notre taux
suffisance je vous remercie
merci
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'Agriculture de
souveraineté alimentaire monsieur Marc
Feydeau merci Monsieur le monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice merci de
cette question
qui fait écho à plusieurs questions qui
m'ont été posées et qui font écho
rapport de la Cour des comptes alors
d'abord je voudrais nous inviter
collectivement à lire la totalité du
rapport de la Cour des comptes et pas se
limiter à la page 9 et aux deux seuls
recommandations qui sont faites ça
serait justice que de l'orange je vais
en dire un mot le travail qui a été fait
par la Cour des comptes deuxième élément
là où on peut avoir et c'est normal
qu'on puisse avoir un débat y compris
avec la Cour des comptes c'est sur
l'équilibrage et le ce qui est proposé
par la Cour des comptes au fond c'est
une simple décroissance et une
décapitalisation qu'il faudrait forcer
pour répondre à des objectifs que par
ailleurs nous avons nécessité de tenir
qui sont des objectifs carbone alors
loin de moi l'idée d'abord de dire que
l'élevage ne doit pas prendre sa part
des efforts qu'il faut faire en termes
de décarbonation d'ailleurs ils se sont
mis sur ce chemin il y a des travaux de
recherche et d'innovation qui portent
par exemple sur l'alimentation qui
permettent de tenir cette trajectoire
loin de moi l'idée de dire que la
consommation était les évolutions de
consommation ne sont pas à tenir au
compte depuis 20 ou 30 ans on sait que
structurellement il y a une baisse de la
consommation et que parfois on se on va
de vers la viande de la viande rouge
vers de Blanche donc tout ça c'est des
choses qu'il faut regarder en lucidité
mais en revanche il y a quelque chose
qui est choquant c'est de proposer comme
seul perspective à un éleveur c'est ça
fait partie des deux recommandations
c'est finalement de ne plus être éleveur
et ça c'est quelque chose qui me
semble-t-il n'est pas acceptable d'abord
parce que maintenant ça n'est pas
acceptable et qu'est-ce que deuxièmement
sur ces territoires là en particulier
les bovins il n'y a pas d'autres
solutions que faire de l'élevage ou rien
et troisième élément et d'ailleurs la
Cour des comptes le dit et ça j'invite à
le regarder quand même c'est comment on
tient mieux compte des autres services
grand l'élevage que celui d’abord de
nous alimenter qui est quand même un
service important et on a besoin je
pense de réfléchir à ce que sont les
équilibres de viande et quel est les
matières de viande qu'on a besoin de
produire en France pour répondre aux
besoins de consommation mais
deuxièmement quelles sont les aménités
comme on dit qu'apporte l'élevage en
particulier les haies le maintien des
paysages ouverts la lutte contre les
incendies de forêts le maintien des
prairies la préservation de la
biodiversité tout ça ça a de la valeur
et donc tout ça il faut il faut en
rendre compte il faut aussi en rendre
compte dans les soutiens financiers qui
sont apportés à l'élevage et donc le
caricaturons pas les uns les autres on a
besoin d'avoir une trajectoire carbone
au niveau national mais on a besoin
aussi de respecter les éleveurs dans
leur travail et dans les différentes
utilités et à méditer qu'ils apportent à
la société française tout entière
madame ce logo oui je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre parce que vous me
prouvez que et je le savais déjà que
vous connaissez le monde de l'élevage
monsieur le Président le connaît très
bien également et moi un petit peu parce
qu'on avait l'impression que les experts
avaient pu aller se mettre dans une
prairie il peut mesurer d'un côté le
méthane émis et puis ce qui est capté
mais vous qui vous y connaissez vous
savez qu'une vache qui pète au Brésil ou
au Canada a exactement le même effet sur
la planète que si elle le fait en France
donc
[Applaudissements]
blague à part monsieur le ministre mais
vous avez compris ce que je voulais vous
dire dans les cils politiques publiques
maintenant et les experts de la Cour des
comptes doivent tenir compte du bilan
carbone dans les évaluations des
politiques publiques alors il va falloir
cesser de soutenir le pouvoir d'achat
des ménagères qui mettent dans leur
caddie des bananes ou du café qui ont ce
sont des produits qui ont un bilan
carbone déplorable
merci la parole de notre collègue Pascal
Alisa pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
face à ces disparités la Commission
européenne souhaite semble-t-il
harmoniser la définition des cidres
commercialisés et les professionnels
s'inquiètent d'une harmonisation par le
bas qui serait préjudiciable à cette
filière par conséquent monsieur le
ministre ou en son réellement les
travaux sur ce sujet et comment le
gouvernement entendit-il préserver le
cidre français et nos spécificités au
niveau européen
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre d'agriculture et de
souveraineté alimentaire monsieur Marc
fedo merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur vous m'interrogez
sur la question de la filière cidre nous
sommes nombreux y compris la première
ministre être sensible à la question du
cidre
un bon dormant que certains d'entre vous
sont il y a plusieurs sujets mais le
sujet principal que vous posez c'est la
question de l'harmonisation du droit
et de l'étiquetage au fond du cidre la
vérité c'est que la situation
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de règle
et que chacun peut dénommé cidre ou
Sider d'ailleurs dans certains pays des
produits qui ne sont pas avec les mêmes
degrés d'exigence le premier degré
d'exigence vous l'avez dit avec une
formule c'est que quand vous buvez du
cidre en France il est à 100% le produit
de pommes et il n'est pas mélangé à
autre chose et donc la position
la position qui est défendue par la
France au niveau européen dans cette
caisse contexte d'harmonisation c'est
bien une harmonisation qui tire tout le
monde vers le haut et qui fasse en sorte
qu'on essaie de sortir de la situation
dans laquelle on est ce que nous sommes
à frontière ouverte ou des gens peuvent
se réclamer de l'appellation enfin de
l'appellation de la dénomination cible
sans en être vraiment et qui permettent
de mieux valoriser la qualité du cidre
français en particulier de la région que
vous connaissez bien et donc c'est
là-dessus qu'on essaie de travailler
avec la commission la le sujet européen
et c'est toujours le même à la vérité
c'est pas le sujet n'est pas d'avoir
raison défendu une position de trouver
le sujet c'est trouver une majorité
et d'arriver à convaincre les collègues
et donc c'est le travail qu'on fait
actuellement au niveau européen pour
faire en sorte qu'on reconnaisse bien la
qualité du site en ce qu'il est le
composé à 100% de pommes et que pour le
reste on peut appeler ça comme on veut
mais qu'on peut pas l'appeler cidre si
on est dans le registre d'une
harmonisation européenne quels sont les
éléments que je peux vous dire
aujourd'hui on a un processus qui est
assez long mais pour la France n'est pas
acceptable que ce soit quelque chose qui
viendrait dégrader la qualité du cidre
français parce que elle est reconnue au
travers par les Français les reconnaît
au-delà des frontières et donc on a
besoin de le mieux la faire reconnaître
et donc l'étiquetage est un élément
important
monsieur ELISA
merci Monsieur le Ministre effectivement
la Commission européenne précise que ce
rapport je cite ne conduira pas
forcément à une proposition législative
or nous savons bien que en fait la pomme
ne tombe jamais bien loin de l'arbre
donc la méfiance et la vigilance doivent
être de mise car on connaît le zèle de
certains normateurs et on connaît aussi
leur capacité à prendre le bon sens à
contre-pied vous l'avez compris monsieur
le ministre on compte sur vous
merci
la parole est à notre collègienne
chanterelle pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'éducation nationale le 1er
mars dernier à l'initiative de notre
groupe nous organisions dans cette
hémicycle un débat sur la mixité sociale
à l'école le constat implacable était
partagé sur l'ensemble de nos bancs
alors qu'en moyenne la proportion
d'élèves issues des milieux défavorisés
et de 42,6% dans le public elle est
seulement de 18% dans le privé ces
écarts ne cessent de se creuser depuis
20 ans nous allons vers un système
scolaire à deux vitesses une école
privée réservée aux enfants privilégiés
et une école publique pour tous les
autres voilà le véritable séparatisme à
l'oeuvre dans notre pays à l'occasion de
ce débat du 1er mars le ministre de
l'éducation nationale disait je cite
parce que l'argent public finance
l'enseignement privé sous contrat à
hauteur de 73% je le rappelle il est
normal exiger de ce dernier qu'il
favorise aussi la mixité des élèves il
parlait alors de moyens de pression sur
les établissements privés sous contrat
notamment en modulant leur subventions
sous forme de bonus malus mais aussi en
juin sur les allocations de poste il
avait même abordé la question de la
sectorisation dont vous estimiez qu'elle
avait donné des résultats probants nous
attendions donc avec impatience des
annonces fortes de la part du
gouvernement pour mettre fin à cette
ségrégation scolaire qui mine notre
pacte social est fait de notre pays un
des plus inégalitaires de l'OCDE le
protocole d'accord que vous avez dévoilé
le 17 mai après deux reports affecte il
ne comporte ni exigence contraignante ni
modulation des subventions des
allocations de poste ni bonus malus et
encore moins de sectorisation nous
comprenons donc que ce gouvernement qui
défend toujours les plus privilégiés
n'agira pas pour plus de mixité scolaire
quand prendrez-vous la mesure du
problème en agissant fortement pour des
mesures contraignantes pour mettre la
mixité scolaire dans les écoles de
France
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre déléguée chargée de
l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Yann chanterelle tout d'abord
je vous prie bien vouloir excuser
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale Pape Ndiaye qui est retenu sur
le prix non au harcèlement vous le savez
notre ambition et d'avoir une action
résolument concrète de réduction de la
ségrégation sociale de nos
établissements scolaires nous ne pouvons
nous satisfaire en effet de la situation
actuelle l'écart de composition sociale
entre élèves des établissements du
public mais aussi entre établissement du
public et du privé se creuse depuis les
années 2000 et vous l'avez rappelé pour
y remédier le ministre de l'éducation
nationale a d'abord voulu agir sur les
établissements publics qui je le
rappelle rassemble 90% des élèves c'est
pourquoi il a demandé à l'ensemble des
recettes de s'emparer de différents
leviers avec pour objectif de faire
progresser de 20% la mixité sociale dans
les établissements publics d'ici à 2027
en ce qui concerne l'enseignement privé
le ministre a toujours souhaité
privilégier la concertation à la
contrainte sur ce sujet d'autant que la
préoccupation de la mixité sociale et
scolaire et plus que partager par
l'enseignement catholique et qu'ils ont
très vite montré leur volonté de
s'engager sur ce sujet et c'est bien
grâce à cette concertation fruit d'un
travail de plusieurs mois que nous avons
pu signer mercredi dernier un a
protocole d'engagement commun avec le
secrétaire général de l'Enseignement
Catholique cela n'avait pas été fait
depuis plus de 30 ans et je crois qu'il
faut le souligner ce protocole il
prévoit notamment de suivre avec des
indicateurs précis les effets de ces
actions à travers l'évolution de la
mixité sociale et scolaire au sein des
établissements privés sous contrat je
crois que c'est une avancée importante
qu'il faut pouvoir souligner vous voyez
pour que cette politique en faveur de
l'égalité des chances pour que tous nos
élèves réussissent nous pensons qu'il
faut convaincre et non contraindre merci
la parole est à notre collègue Pierre
Charon pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale c'est toujours désagréable de
s'adresser à un absent en 2022 pour
faire face à la hausse continue des
atteintes à la laïcité vous avez élaboré
un plan depuis la publication de ce plan
que constate-t-on au mois d'octobre
dernier le nombre de signalements avait
atteint 720 une hausse de 130% par
rapport au mois précédent au mois de
mars il est encore été passé les 500 cas
monsieur le ministre comme vous l'avez
déclaré la hausse du mois d'octobre est
liée à la commémoration de l'assassinat
de Samuel Paty les 50 cas du mois de
mars correspondent à une remontée chaque
année au moment du Ramadan dites-vous
aux explications très catégoriques n'ont
d'ailleurs réussi qu'une seule chose
soulever une polémique et notamment par
la Grande Mosquée de Paris quant au mois
d'avril dans l'académie de Paris les
données qui ont été communiquées par vos
services ne sont pas bonnes je vous
laisse le soin de les annoncer ce sont
des chiffres les plus élevés depuis la
rentrée de septembre il faut aussi y
ajouter des signalements d'antisémitisme
qui eux ne relèvent pas d'atteinte à la
laïcité mais les procédures pénales aux
statistiques sont-elles fiables et
surtout sont inutiles la réponse est non
vos chiffres sont manifestement
sous-estimés pour le principal syndicat
des personnels de direction des collèges
et lycées les tenues litigieuses et
contestations d'enseignement ou même les
difficultés en sortie scolaire ne font
pas l'objet de signalement de manière
systématique vos statistiques sont
inutiles la réponse est encore non
ces chiffres ne traduisent en aucune
réponse aux attaques entre la laïcité
l'échelle d'établissement se sentent
bien seuls ils attendent des réponses
concrètes il vous demande des outils
réglementaires pour mieux gérer ces
situations
votre absence de fermeté sur tous les
sujets maintient la porte ouverte à
toutes les revendications communautaires
ma question est simple elle est vous
monsieur le ministre vous contentez
moins après moi de recenser les
atteintes à la laïcité et de les
commenter ou allez-vous enfin donner aux
responsables d'établissements des
directives claires merci
pour vos réponses la parole est à la
ministre délégués chargés de
l'enseignement madame Grandjean
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Charron afin de répondre à
votre question je souhaite rappeler
plusieurs actions engagées par Monsieur
le Ministre de l'Éducation nationale et
de la jeunesse qui je le rappelle est
absent pour cause de remise de prix sur
le l'enjeu de la lutte contre le
harcèlement le ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse à demander
une publication des chiffres mensuels
des atteintes à la laïcité que vous avez
rappelé ces chiffres sont désormais
visibles disponibles sur le site du
ministère de l'Éducation nationale pour
plus de transparence plus de suivi et
organiser cette mobilisation pour la
lutte contre les atteintes à la laïcité
le ministre de l'éducation nationale a
souhaité là où c'est nécessaire renforcé
des équipes valeur de la République et à
élargi la formation de tous les
personnels de l'Éducation nationale je
voudrais le rappeler le plan que le
ministre a annoncé en novembre 202 a
déjà permis à 300 000 personnels
d'éducation dont 5000 chefs
d'établissement et adjoints à être
formés sur le sujet je crois que cette
formation est absolument concrète elle
permet aux uns et aux autres d'être
mieux accompagnés mieux avec des outils
qui leur permettent de lutter
efficacement contre ces atteintes à la
laïcité le ministre de l'éducation
nationale a également renforcé les
mesures du disciplinaire en cas
d'atteinte au principe de laïcité en
diffusant une circulaire très claire au
chef d'établissement qui jusqu'à présent
restait dans le flou quant aux
procédures à mettre en oeuvre le
ministre de l'éducation nationale a
également institut de finalisé le
conseil des sages et de la laïcité en
nommant enfant ses membres 5 ans après
la création de cette entité les membres
historiques ont d'ailleurs tous été
confirmés dans ces fonctions
je voudrais monsieur le sénateur que
nous puissions partager l'engagement du
gouvernement et du ministre de
l'éducation nationale sans faille pour
lutter contre ces atteintes à la laïcité
je crois que au-delà des mots les
actions sont les plus fortes
l'accompagnement des personnels
l'engagement bien sûr de cela mais aussi
l'organisation des mesures
disciplinaires qui sont donc passées par
voie réglementaires récemment encore
merci Monsieur Charron si vous le
souhaitez vous avez quelques secondes
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Brigitte l'herbier pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier le ministre monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur mes chers collègues
dimanche matin au commissariat de
Roubaix une équipe de policiers sur la
relève de nuit appel de détresse d'une
jeune fille cette mission est confiée à
une jeune patrouille de policier
recueillir cette mineure présumée violée
pour la protéger et la conduire à
l'hôpital cette précipitation au service
de l'autre sera la dernière pour Paul
Steven et Manon ce matin là ils sont
partis de chez eux heureux ils ne savait
pas qu'il ne reverrai jamais leurs
proches à Roubaix il y a une vraie
solidarité entre la police nationale
municipale les pompiers c'est une ville
méritante
à l'École nationale de police de Roubaix
la directrice la commissaire kitchenko
apprend aux nouvelles recrues les
difficultés de la profession il faudra
beaucoup de professionnels et de rigueur
pour exercer ce métier
Manon stagiaire était prête à entrer
dans cette grande famille
Kader Haroun le commissaire principal de
Roubaix dirige le commissariat avec
bienveillance et fermeté
il leur a dit combien la police était un
vrai ascenseur social pour tous ceux qui
ont à cœur de défendre les valeurs de la
République monsieur le ministre vous
êtes fier de vos hommes vous êtes bien
raison de les défendre la mort de ces
trois jeunes policiers de Roubaix
prouvent encore une fois les risques de
ce métier ils ont été tués par un
chauffard
ivre sous l'emprise de stupéfiants
roulant en grande vitesse à contresens
et connue des services de police leur
décès est un choc immense pour tout leur
collègues leurs proches le nord et plus
largement pour notre pays tout entier ce
qui s'est produit est inacceptable au
nom de tous mes collègues j'adresse mes
sincères condoléances aux familles aux
proches des jeunes aujourd'hui on se
recueille monsieur le ministre que
pouvons-nous faire dès demain pour
stopper ce fléau
je me dois de vous demander monsieur le
ministre si le Gouvernement entend
prendre des mesures pour intensifier la
lutte contre les conducteurs dangereux
sous emprise de drogue ou d'alcool et si
l'envisage de durcir les peines
encourues par le recruteur ou autre pour
vous répondre la parole est comme ils
disent de l'intérieur des Outre-mer
monsieur Darmanin
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Brigitte l'herbier merci des
mots très touchants que vous avez eu
pour ces trois jeunes policiers du
commissariat de Roubaix un commissariat
parmi les plus difficiles de France qui
compte énormément de moyens à la hauteur
sans doute du dur métier que font les
policiers et les personnes
administratifs de ce site qui vous le
savez vous avez cité le commissaire
Haroun fait l'honneur de la police
nationale moi je veux d'abord dire aux
familles de ces policiers de mal
président de la République le rendra
officiellement hommage à l'École
nationale de police de Roubaix qu'ils
font l'honneur à 24 à 25 à 26 ans de la
France du service public et nous pensons
tous à leur famille à ce petit enfant
d'un an qui aurait eu un an dans les
jours qui viennent et à cette jeune
femme qui est enceinte d'un de ces
jeunes policiers et c'est assassin celui
qui était dans la voiture
averse parce qu'il faut utiliser les
mots qui comptent à tuer non seulement
trois destin mais abaisser l'intégralité
de la police nationale
alors après l'hommage il y a évidemment
réfléchir madame la sénatrice et avec
d'autres faits divers parce que ce n'est
pas le seul trop de chauffard trop
d'assassins tu sur les routes sous
l'emprise de stupéfiants et d'alcool
nous a travaillons avec le garde des
sceaux pour évidemment pouvoir réussir à
limiter ces drames nous avons proposé le
retrait des 12 points pour ceux qui
consomment son stupéfiants c'est une
mesure réglementaire le garde des soins
proposé de renommer cette homicide comme
un homicide routier c'est attendu il y a
beaucoup de propositions d'ailleurs de
votre assemblée elle est surtout les
bancs je peux vous assurer que sur
l'autorité de la première ministre avec
Monsieur le gardeesseau et en espérant
que d'autres drames sont invités par le
travail que font les policiers des
gendarmes tous les jours sur les routes
pour éviter que ces chauffards de
continuer à tuer nous sommes à
disposition du Parlement et du Sénat et
de vous-même pour pouvoir travailler
dans ce sens en la mémoire de ces trois
jeunes policiers je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
nous avons terminé avec les questions
gouvernement je vous rappelle que les
prochaines questions ont lieu le
mercredi 31 mai à 15h je vais suspendre
la séance ce sera reprise à 16h30 pour
l'examen de quatre conventions
internationales puis du projet de loi
visant à donner à la douane les moyens
de faire face aux nouvelles menaces la
séance est suspendue